um yo on this record uh you dropped 16
which I think is dope because you're
getting your [__] off on that oh thanks
give me some yo what so what job did you
get fired from
oh man I had like a a job at a like when
I was I had tons of jobs I had every
single job like grocery store bartending
waitressing but it was like a bartending
job I didn't oh yeah it was a bartending
job and you just told me to go [__] them
and Foot Locker too Footlocker yeah but
I had I have a great relationship with
Footlocker look I I I was like employee
of the year really no no no not really
but could could you like were you like
top tier assistant are you back during
any of the shoes no I had keys and
everything I was super responsible like
good employee I was that girl yeah so
you weren't like if the pair of Jordans
came in no I wasn't stealing no no I'm
not saying stealing but you might set up
a parasite for you for the homie like
you know yeah I did that a few times
yeah yeah I used to do that for my
friends what was the last real job you
had was it the bartending thing yeah
and you just like did you literally tell
him [__] you when you when you got fired
no I didn't actually not that one
um
one of them yeah but not not the last
one so you could make a drink like you
could make like a yeah I'm actually like
I can make it I'm really a chef
what can you cook everything literally
everything when you say you're really a
chef what does that mean like the same
do you have like a certificate that says
so
are you just I'm a hood Chef you're a
hood Chef okay yes so what's like the
go-to if I had to be like okay Shelby
like what is your what are you gonna
make there you're very confident in
um well what do you like I'm I'm into
everything
I'm a fat [__] as we discussed like I
got some famous dishes of mine like if
you had to cook a dish for uh
give me the Gordon Ramsay dish he's
sitting there all right like I'm a
cookie so I would make it I would make a
medley of things okay because I I feel
as though if I have a medley I can't
lose if you don't like one thing he's
gonna like another thing so I would do
like these um lamb chops that I do these
garlic Char mint lamb chops the mint
okay they very like taste level like
very very high like it's not even
regular at all and then I would do a
Chilean sea bass
oh and then
I would do uh on another day if you come
I would do coconut curry chicken and
white rice Jesus that's a famous meal of
mine the people go crazy for you see
he's not in his head people go crazy and
the people go absolutely insane and last
but not least lasagna rolls talk about
it that sounds fire
yo the best Italian food I ever had was
in Boston A Little Italy and there's
like those little bakeries that stay
open all night yeah oh my God cannolis
oh my goodness I miss a cannoli every
guy at the [__] club from DJ and [__]
face and there was a [__] Bakery open
at three in the morning like what the
[__] is going on over here I love a
bakery so lasagna rolls would you ever
okay because right now you know there's
just like all these rappers are doing
like an artist like uh Mr Beast all
these guys they're doing like a ghost
kitchens right yes so you could do like
b as bites oh you come on with ideas and
then you could just license it to a
ghost kitchen and come up with their own
menu and then give them the recipes and
then you know people all over the world
can just but they'll have then they'll
have my recipes
I mean it could be like a watered down
version of the recipe like I feel like a
lasagna roll would be like like let me
get six of those like in a little box
yeah it's like that yeah yeah
you should do that you know what next
time I come I might bring a lasagna
roast that would be amazing yeah next
time I come here I'll bring lasagna
rolls I'll break my diet for that okay
I'm on a keto diet
just because I like to brag about how
good it is and then people then you can
then you can vouch for me so I don't
have to do the talking next time you'd
be like you know who's a really good
Chef yeah